at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this podcast is
brought to you by mizzen and main don't
worry about the spelling all you need to
know is this I have organized my entire
life around avoiding fancy shirts
because you have to iron them you sweat
through them they smell really easily
they're a pain in the ass Mizanin mane
has given me the only shirt that I need
and what I mean by that and Kelly
Starrett loves these shirts as well is
that you can trick people they look
really fancy so you can take them out to
nice dinners whatever but they're made
from athletic sweat wicking material so
you can throw this thing into your
luggage in a heap or on your kitchen
table like I did recently and then pull
it out throw it on with no ironing no
steaming no nothing walk out and you
could probably wear this thing for a
week straight or make it your only dress
shirt and take it on trips for weeks at
a time never wash it it will not smell
you will not sweat through it you got to
check these things out so go to 4-hour
workweek comm all spelled out four hour
workweek comm forward slash shirts check
it out
four hour workweek comm forward slash
shirts and you'll see some of my
favorite gear including the one shirt
that I've been traveling with
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I've used
99designs for everything from banner ads
to book covers including sketches and
mock-ups that led to the 4-hour body
which later became number one New York
Times number one Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming a lot of it took place
with designers from around the world and
here's how it works whether you need a
t-shirt a business card a website and
app thumbnail whatever it might be you
submit that project and designers from
around the world will send you sketches
and mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward
and many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the
future but in the meantime if you want
to see some of my competitions some of
the book covers as well as get a free
$99 upgrade go to 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim that's 99designs com
forward slash Tim
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss staring out through my window
with the eucalyptus trees swaying in the
breeze but that's enough poetry for this
episode of the Tim Ferriss show the Tim
Ferriss show of course like every other
episode is intended to help you
deconstruct excellence world-class
performers to pull out the tricks
routines habits books etc that you can
use you can emulate to improve results
in your own life and guests vary from
hedge fund traders to that does make any
sense at all
hedge fund managers to top performing
angel investors to people like Arnold
Schwarzenegger on the celebrity front
chest prodigies and in this case we have
not only a chef but a a chef Plus policy
maker plus would be professional athlete
his name is Sam Kass Sam is a
fascinating guy he went from getting a
history major at you Chicago before that
he was on the professional baseball
track then became private chef for the
Obamas and then ended up the senior
policy advisor for nutrition at the
White House
he ran or helped to run as executive
director the let's move campaign which
used private sector partnerships to
pursue the goal of reducing childhood
obesity to just 5 percent by 2030 and
for that he was named number 11 on Fast
Company magazine's 2011 list of the 100
most creative people and it's such a
multi-faceted story Sam is a a hilarious
story teller and there are a lot of
really concrete takeaways the book that
he could not recall offhand in this
episode is a history of world
agriculture by Marcel Missouri and
Lawrence rude are or rude art are oh you
dar T so in addition to the art of
fielding auto leggies books and some of
the others that he mentioned there you
have it a history of world agriculture
so now without further ado please enjoy
my conversation and our conversation
with Sam Kass
Sam welcome to the show
so good to be here man I'm excited yeah
it's uh it's an interview that I've been
really looking forward to and I am very
very hopped up on caffeine this is that
this is an Amish morning for me I know
this is I'm usually a 10:00 a.m. 11:00
a.m. kind of guy cuz I'm a night owl and
so I'm gonna jump in do some morning
questions in a second but I wanted to
first congratulate you on the James
Beard Foundation the Leadership Awards
thank you that yeah that means a lot
it's a James Beard has been an
incredible organization I mean they are
like the the the they're like that you
know the Oscars for chefs and but
they've taken up a lot of the important
issues around food and nutrition and
health and sustainability so they have
an award for that and yeah it's a great
honor I'm excited yeah so for those who
don't know the Leadership Awards and
this is uh from their website quote
recognize specific outstanding
initiatives as well as bodies of work
and lifetime achievement so that's
that's a hell of a tagline and we're
going to get into all that but first a
very important question eggs how do you
refer to make eggs in the morning ha ha
so actually I've been eating a lot of
eggs these days and you know the eggs
are one of the hardest things to cook
some of the great chefs in the world
they're actually they're test for a new
cook would be how to make an omelet
would be like their one master test so I
actually like eggs always almost always
soft though so either a soft-boiled egg
I'll do eggs over easy or really soft
scrambled eggs I guess that did the
trick for soft scrambled eggs is I you
know if you get your butter nice not I
crack the eggs straight into the pan let
them cook for a second and then mix them
up and then before you think they're
done take them out because they'll
harden a little bit as they sit on the
plate but I'll eat eggs pretty much any
anyway and do youare you a tea guy a
coffee guy I'm going to be above both
all of the above I do I'll do coffee in
the morning a little half an F and then
either a little coffee in the day or tea
and then I'll definitely have some tea
at night
some chamomile tea or mint tea or some
but I drink them both how do you have
any particular like do you have any
particular type of coffee or way of
prepping or is it just you know what
just treated as fuel whatever will get
me through the day mmm you know I I
wouldn't say that I'm like one of those
coffee like lunatics who like you know
as wild though you know about every
specific thing and talks about it like
wine but I appreciate a good cup of
coffee and I really one of my least
favorite things is a terrible cup of
coffee yeah I just I can't I can't drink
it so I'm a big Stumptown guy you know
blue bottle does a great cup of coffee
there's there's some really good coffee
out there so I do French press in the
morning real simple some half an ass
nothing's nothing crazy what does the
well actually I'm gonna ask the the
morning routine question a little bit
later on but you mentioned coffee snobs
and this is kind of a good segue because
you live in Brooklyn but you came from a
town that is actually really well-known
for coffee these days which is Chicago
yeah and correct me if I'm wrong I could
get some of my bio incorrect but you
grew up with parents who were both
teachers is that correct
my dad's a teacher was growing up well
he was actually he worked in the Ford
factory when I was very young and then
he transferred occation stuff but more
from like museums and now she's at the
National Science Foundation so but lots
of teachers my own uncle or teachers my
cousins are teachers my sister's a
teacher so I I am we come from I come
from an educational family what was what
was that like growing up I mean how did
that impact you or affect you it
probably was more how I pushed back
against it then how it in that that was
probably the drunkest influence I wanted
to be professional baseball player from
the time I was like three all the way
through college to be honest and I went
to junior college trying to make it to
the major league so I I you know as my
parents pleaded with me to dig into the
books and hit them harder all I wanted
to do was take batting practice and and
and you know go after some fly ball so
it came back to me when I when I
transferred in college and and then
beyond did the Diaz brothers and sisters
I have a younger sister who's still in
Chicago got it and you ultimately in
college ended up at you Chicago and what
what drew you to baseball
why did you why'd you play baseball um
so I love I love baseball for a number
of reasons one it is so hard I mean if
you if you are successful thirty percent
of the time for your whole career you'll
be a hall-of-famer it means if you fail
seven out of ten times you're one of the
greatest players in the history of the
game and so that constant challenge and
constant challenge to get better
something that you know always really
drew me it's also you know it's a team
sport so you have the camaraderie that
is you know really powerful and those
bombs with with your teammates but it's
it's also an utterly individual sport so
unlike you know soccer basketball where
if you having a bad game you kind of
blend in if you make an error in
baseball or you strike out with the
bases loaded everybody knows like you
messed up and so you really have to take
account you know responsibility and
you're held accountable for your actions
and I think that those kind of lessons
of discipline hard work but also
accountability and learning how to fail
and even if you failed five times in a
row
that's six time you get a shot at it
maybe the most important time can win
the game and how do you mentally prepare
yourself to walk into that moment
clear-headed and and not carrying the
baggage from those previous failures
which could you know impede your ability
to be successful when it mattered like
those are the kind of things that I just
loved about baseball and it really
struck me well and all other aspects of
life and you had a you had a very good
batting average it's it I have read that
it was ranked among the best in program
history at University of Chicago is that
accurate
yeah I haven't checked recently I'm sure
some of the younger guys that have taken
over I when I left I think I was number
three but you know it wasn't uh you know
we were you see for the education not
not the baseball but we had a very good
team and I played two years of junior
college baseball it's just trying to get
drafted where basically all I did was
play ball
six hours a day seven days a week
literally and sprint training in the
morning like you know that's all we did
so UFC was a little different it was two
hours a day five days a week and I'll
never forget the first practice when
coach outlined our schedule and said
that on Thursdays we didn't practice
because we had science labs I just
almost like past that I didn't even know
what what I'm talking about science labs
not baseball so it was it was an
adjustment for me but but it was one of
the greatest thing probably the best
decision I've ever made was to go there
and well like you said I mean if you go
to say Iowa for wrestling I mean
wrestling is your career in college
academics are secondary but a UChicago
you have obviously a very strenuous
academic program what did you do that
other players didn't do that allowed you
to not only make it through you Chicago
and the academics but to have that high
a batting average for that good
abandoning average that's a good
question I'm not exactly sure I know a
definitive answer that I mean I had come
from such a rigorous baseball background
where a lot of the other guys were you
know came for you know we're sort of
playing baseball secondarily that you
know that part came really easy to me
and you know I think the part that was a
real adjustment and that I could learn
from them was like how to really hit the
books in a way that I had never had it
the books before and how do you organize
all that classwork and you know the
expectation that you're supposed to read
like five books a week I mean I mean
that was like absurd to me going in so
you know I learned from them about how
to balance that side of it and from my
side you know I think the discipline and
how do you efficiently use your time
both in the you know in the gym in
batting practice like how do you make
the most of what you're you know what
you're trying to get out of it I think
of something that I could bring you know
to the guys and and was able to be
successful on both sides and the the the
the major you ended up choosing was
history did was that it was not an
immediate choice did you know you wanted
to do history how did you arrive at that
you know I looked I looked at a couple
other major
but I ride the history because you know
at the time there's a lot of things
swirling in politics there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of work there's
like you know their first Gulf War and
there's a lot of things going on that
that I was paying attention to that I
didn't really understand what was
happening and and I and I realized that
if I wanted to understand the world
around me in politics and and everything
that was happening having a much better
grasp on history and where these things
have come from was gonna help me and I
think that that really propelled me to
focus in on history which which I love
I'm a history geek do you have any
favorite history books or biographies oh
man that's so tough that's so tough I
don't know if I have one I'll tell you
like III like some obscure ones and I
gotta get to the author but there's like
it there's a history of agriculture book
that completely changed my perspective
and it's kind of boring but when you
look at you know if you're a geek and
you look at like the impact of simple
tools have had on our society the
transformational shifts like we forget
how fundamental that stuff is so I'll
get back to you on that there's so many
great biographies and great history
books cool
yeah the the I'll put the the title of
the book and so on in the show notes so
we'll come back to that
how did you then this is kind of the
missing piece in the Sam Kass puzzle
that I haven't immediately been able to
figure out how did you go then from
majoring in history at you Chicago to
food how did you become interested in
food so I had always sort of loved food
you know as a kid I kind of liked to
cook but it had no notion of ever you
know pursuing it professionally in any
way and when I was at UC my friend was
the sous chef at this restaurant in in
in Chicago and I I didn't know him super
well but I said oh you know one day you
know I think I'll go to culinary school
when I'm old and just so I can learn how
to cook for like my kids and wife
whenever they decide to show up and he
was like you know well don't do that
just come in and hang out at the
restaurant see what you think so I went
in it was like an italian-american spot
in Chicago nothing you know nice place
not the too fancy
and and I loved it and so I ended up
just showing up and like you know scrub
and potatoes and hanging out and trying
to learn some things and the chef said
well if you're gonna keep showing up I
guess I gotta pay you so I'd so he did
but I mean it was pretty much an
unmitigated disaster like I knew nothing
and they you know out but I always work
hard so they they threw me on the line
to work the pasta station and oh my god
it was you know the dishes that the chef
let me send at the table most often came
back because they were just on that of
all so it you know so it was a rough
start
um but so I had that one summer and then
I finished UC and I had one one semester
left and I kind of kicked my way into an
abroad program I got I got wait-listed
and I sort of pleat and made a strong
plea with the Dean to let me let me into
one of the programs I didn't care where
where we went where I went and just went
to ended up going to Vienna and I I said
to the head of the program you know I'm
I worked a little I worked this one
summer in a restaurant I'm interested in
food like maybe there's a pastry shop or
something I can go hang and hang out at
one so once a week or something totally
casual so I landed in Vienna and she
said so my husband's uncle's friend from
college son rides bicycles with the
sous-chef of the best restaurant in
Vienna that's literally what it was and
and she was like you know he can meet
you tomorrow if you're interested it's
like all right so I meet this dude crazy
guy and he comes up to me and says are
you the Yankee who wants to cook on the
street and I said I am and he said all
right well we'll come come to the
restaurant tomorrow and so I did and it
was a Michelin star like best restaurant
in Vienna I was incredible I knew
nothing about food and they ended up
taking me in and training me sort of
old-school European style like kick your
butt and you know until you you know
can't take it anymore and you figure it
out and lots of stories from that from
that from that place but that's sort of
how I really was propelled into
so uh a few things I just want to
explain for people maybe not in the
industry so shoot a sous-chef is I guess
that means under Chef right that's kind
of a second-in-command in the kitchen is
that for that but just like sous-vide is
under under pressure I guess and the so
there are a lot of stories I know we we
talked about one over dinner the other
night and I can't skip it so could you
tell people about your sort of baptism
by fire in that kitchen so many stories
I think the one yeah the the the fever
dream
a fever dream yeah so so it was December
and and that's the busiest time of the
year by far for this restaurant
yeah and the the guy who did all the
fish meats and sauces what had to have
surgery and so the executive chef had to
take over for him and now he was like 40
and was a super talented guy but was
like not cooking anymore like he was
running things and being out with the
guests and you know doing his thing so
he was really unhappy about having to
cook the line during the most busy time
of the year so he he like he walked in
when when we got news is like RI Yankee
you're with me and so he had this huge
incentive to teach me how to prep
everything as fast as possible because
he didn't want to have to do it so he
taught me how to make all the sauces
prep all the meats cook everything and
so then we would work the service
together but in the middle of the month
on a Friday the chef came down with like
a hundred and four fever and was
completely laid out and it just so
happened that my best friend who was a
Rhodes Scholar at the time was coming to
visit me from England and so you know
we're supposed to go hang on I was
supposed to have the weekend off and we
were just gonna hang and so he shows up
and I'm like amen you're coming with me
I'm putting you in a chef's coat like we
can't leave and they had the breakfast
cooked this guy Wolfgang who was that
awesome dude but you know he was like he
was like doing platters of fruit and
he's a good cook but he didn't like cook
dinner service he never had so it was
the three of us trying to figure out
this dinner service and it was pretty
by but at the end of the night the
sous-chef said all right Wolfgang you
got to take the day off it's it's the
two Yankees on the stove tomorrow night
and like the kitchen went silent like
all the cooks were like like they
couldn't believe it and so we figured
out this system my friends are smart
guys so he we studied the the words in
German of the different like fish and
meats and whatever we needed so the next
night we had like a great we were packed
and so the the sous-chef had caught the
order my friend would take out the fish
or the meat and then I would cook it and
you and you know as I'm cooking on the
other side of me also cooking and facing
me was the guy who did all the
vegetables and side dishes that would go
with my meter fish and I'd look up and
he would just be standing there kind of
with his mouth open completely in awe of
what was going on because you know that
station that we were working was like
what people would work their whole
careers for it's an incredibly
prestigious well-paid position and here
are these two Americans who knew nothing
about cooking working in the Michelin
star restaurant on the hardest station
in the kitchen it was hysterical and we
made it like we we basically got through
without any catastrophe and I'll never
forget when the last ticket went out the
sous-chef his name was Alice he turns
around he said Yankees we won and then
like just in German shouted four bottles
of champagne and bottles of beer and and
we had a good old party that night it
was it was a it was a ton of fun and I
remember hearing this story and just
having my jaw drop open because I've had
of course very limited exposure to food
and restaurants but during the writing
of the 4-hour chef when we first met and
met up in in DC I remember going into a
handful of restaurants obviously
different restaurants of very different
environments but when you're when you
look at a line not at a Michelin star
restaurant but just at any restaurant
during a busy period and like 40 menus
open at the same time it is complete
chaos I mean you have to be Doctor
Octopus to work one of the hot lines so
it's like you guys who were kind of
yanked out of the audience by the
conductor of the orchestra and asked to
do
violin solos it's it's a I can't believe
you guys made it through that what what
was your internal self-talk like what
you got when you got the news and like
when you got the news or when you walked
in for that
that evening I mean how did you prep
yourself that because I like baseball
right like if you're putting out every
three out of ten dishes is working in
the restaurant right you get punched in
the face so yeah what was your self-talk
- yeah it's a great it's a mean I think
the the key in a restaurant and key in
any kind of high-pressure situation like
I think 75% of success is is staying
calm and not losing your nerve and you
know the rest you figure out but once
you lose your once you lose your your
calm everything else starts falling
apart fast and in a restaurant situation
is the tick tickets start piling up and
like everybody else is waiting on you so
in particularly this like the timing
would have to be perfect cuz you go up
on six dishes and that's the the guys
doing all the sad stuff has like cooked
all this and he's got to get to the next
round so your timing has to be right on
and if you're too slow all of his stuff
gets yes you know it gets overcooked and
he's got to cook it again right so you
can really throw things off then so I
think the key thing was like mentally
preparing myself like when something
goes wrong you just stay calm and stay
the course and I think the other thing
when the first thing the sous-chef
taught me like he gave me some really
fundamental rules which have lasted me
kind of throughout everything I do one
is the first is never serve anything you
wouldn't want to eat like never serve
crack
it's like rule number one rule number
two which is just true just thought you
know you'd have a high standard of
everything you do rule number two was
when things get really busy instead of
just like like plowing ahead and just
trying to work as fast as you can and
just go through all the tickets he
always would tell me sit back and come
up with a plan so look at which dishes
you have and figure out what's the most
efficient way to cook them so if you
have five of one thing don't just cook
them one at a time like get them out
prep them together and do them together
so that those kind of like fundamental
rules I tried to hold really close and
you just come up with a good system and
every great rest
has an incredibly strong system that
when the the the pressure gets heated
you know heated up and the everything's
moving super fast you rely on that
system to move you through and I think
that was key we came up with a good
system and and out it went so I've know
you're not focusing on too many things
at any one time focus on cooking the
things that my friend was giving me and
and it worked really well it was it was
so fascinating for me to visit different
kitchens and look at the layouts and and
the methods because there are really
sort of the the internal workings of the
executive chef thrown out into this the
architecture of the room and the process
and all that and just being so surprised
at for instance Alinea in Chicago and
how quiet it is there's no yelling
there's no screaming it's more like a
operating table that what is the most
unusual restaurant
it's a that puts out very good food that
you've come across in terms of just how
it works
mm-hmm well the craziest kitchen I've
ever seen like so I worked at a Veck
which is one of Chicago one of America's
great restaurants and you know it was
really a wine bar that ended up putting
out such good food that it's one James
Beard Awards and all kinds of other
accolades just because the food and
enough just kicking butt but it was not
set up that at all so it's a teeny line
of three people one big wood burning and
gas burning my kind of oven and a little
stove and what people do out of that
it's just what we were doing out of that
was soon was incredible but the kitchen
that's like blows me away the most is
the kitchen here in Brooklyn actually at
Frankie's 457 it's so tiny
it's literally like two guys on two
induction burners in a space that's like
I don't know like five feet by 10 feet
and they cook for this huge restaurant
at quality it's like one of my favorite
restaurants in America what was her name
again Frankie's 457 it's unbelievably
good and it's like you look at these two
guys back there with it and two
induction burners and I just don't know
I just don't know how they do it and the
menu is huge I mean it's it's still in
it's delicious so what people can do out
of very small spaces is is pretty
incredible so the for people who don't
know what an induction burner is and
then didn't correct me for Ryan an
induction burner is basically a stovetop
that you plug in and you put on a
countertop
maybe it's the size of like a large
dinner plate I mean it depends on what
kind you get but he uses as I understand
it magnets yes metal so you could
actually take the pot off put your hand
right on the burner and not burn your
hand you got to make sure you don't have
rings on but um that actually raises
this this is this question of kind of
elegance right because one of the
questions I was gonna ask you later is
what you know what's the most
interesting meal you could make in a
dorm room right and you could you could
I mean induction burners in a five by
ten foot space I mean that's basically a
dorm room that these guys are cooking in
it sounds like if if you had to limit
your herbs or spices to three choices
for the rest of your life what would
your three
what would your three choices be herbs
or spices oh my god what a horrible
horrible question for me only three yeah
or I let you know I'll give you a little
bit of wiggle room a hand
a handful I mean I'd have to have
chilies of some kinds any kinds there's
lots of kinds but I'd you know some some
chilies I would have to have any herbs
or spices I'm a I'd probably have to
take basil and tarragon I'm a huge
tarragon guy um spices I mean oh my god
how do I pick just one Oh God I don't
know like cumin is a big is a is a
really versatile big spice
I love pink peppercorns although I don't
know if that'd make the cut
yeah that's a really hard question oh I
know that's why that's why I yeah this
is this has to get the to make the
shopping list for myself out tarragon
tarragon kind of revolutionized eggs for
me tarragon and and white truffle sea
salt of all things which was recommended
by a friend of mine how do you use
tarragon manna you can just check on
anything I love it and straight in
salads you could chop it up with like
some parsley and some basil and you can
put that on fish on I use tarragon on
steak stick tarragon like a little
tarragon and maybe even a little butter
on a steak is delicious
anything seafood I find targum goes also
really well with so you could do if
you're doing a pasta like lemon you know
a lemon tarragon something seafood pasta
a filling the blank on the seafood you
pretty much can't go wrong so I it's
it's it's one of those interests you
know you gotta be careful cuz you can
use it's strong so you can overuse it
pretty quickly but if you use it gently
it it's a beautiful flavor
you mentioned steak what is your
favorite cut of steak and why I I guess
favorite I guess I'd have to be a ribeye
guy but I eat a lot of skirt steak a lot
of hanger steak I love braising so you
know lots of different you know the
bridge and cuts ribs and such but if I'm
gonna have like if I'm gonna have my
last steak it would be a ribeye when
you're cooking ribeye for yourself just
just for Sam nobody else how do you how
do you cook it grill you know if I'm
doing for myself but really if I'm doing
for anybody I just throw it on the grill
really simple and like medium-rare to
rare and pretty olive oil salt and just
that sometimes pepper sometimes on I'm
not a big pepper guy so I don't put that
black pepper on much pretty much
anything really but a steak is the kind
of the one thing that I'd be open to
that and yeah then away you go
nothing nothing fancy and you put the
olive oil and salt on beforehand or
afterwards that's before head yeah and
if I'm gonna do an herb like sometimes
I'll put tarragon or some rosemary I
always do that afterwards because I find
that when you put on before just burnt
and you lose the flavor but if you you
hit it africa words particularly you're
going to sear it on the grill
then finish in the oven for a few
minutes which is often the way to do it
if you have a thick cut
you put that on so get the you know it
cooks a little bit to round out the
flavor but doesn't doesn't kill the
flavor yeah I always finish sort of sear
and then finish at the oven at a low
temperature and just let the butter and
whatever herbs I'm going to use kind of
soak in from the top down yeah the so
the pet the pepper point you mentioned
not much of a black pepper guy but you
also mentioned the pink peppercorns so
would what would you use pink
peppercorns for which I've never used I
don't that reason yeah you could I mean
so you could use them on any meat they
like go great on like pork or if you
grind them up as a rub on pork or you
could do on steak as well you can you
can do a fun dressing a salad dressing
with them as part of it but it becomes
part of a flavor where it's like for me
black pepper it's used like salt right
and we use it on everything but salt
doesn't you salt becomes part of the
flavor it elevates the flavor where's
pepper like layers on top of the flavor
and it's it always just kind of blankets
things for me and I don't know I just I
don't I'm just not a fan of that sort of
ubiquitous pepper flavor on everything
and so on the flip side if aside from
tarragon if someone if one of your very
close friends were to say you know I
love Sam but he really over uses this
ingredient what would that ingredient or
condiment or herb or spice be mmm I
don't know probably garlic but we all
are guilty of using garlic too much
because it's just so damn good I
literally have minced garlic in my tea
right now I'm not kidding yeah I'm
guilty of the same sin God how did you
first meet the Obamas so so we're both
from Hyde Park in High Park is on
Southside Chicago where the universe
Chicago is and and you know what he was
a professor
actually I'd known him just from the
neighborhood and the first now first
lady when I was in high school and then
but then lost touch with them for many
years and got reconnected with them when
I came back from my my time in Vienna
and then subsequent travels around the
world a search travel for about four or
five years you know through Vienna and
then passed it so I got reconnected with
them right at the campaign was was uh
was getting going and it was that
through a backer how did you guys end up
reconnecting so we reconnected because
well I base after I when I was in Vienna
I was actually there illegally I had no
workers permit or anything and ended up
sort of getting run out of town yeah
yeah that's a story for another day okay
and so then I spent about four for you
for more years past that trip cooking
and traveling and I ended up getting
connected to a family that had a place
in New Zealand and so I cooked a couple
seasons down in New Zealand and they
were from Chicago so I the second season
I came back with them to to Chicago to
work part-time and the the father of
that family knew the first lady and
happened to run into her on a plane and
they got to talking and you know and he
was telling them telling the the first
city about you know me cooking for them
and and and she else am I would seen him
in years and so we got reconnected and
you know back then there was no staff it
was basically just them grandma little
they had a little bit of help but but
not much so started helping out the
first lady is she had to get on the the
campaign trail more and more when the
kids were still very young and so
started helping her out with it with
cooking some better food for them what
meals what were some favorite meals
during that that intense campaigning
period oh you know that's all top secret
and I can't disclose no just kidding
okay you know look and during that time
and all the way through and
they there's there's never been any
interest in fancy food at all really
simple food that everybody's gonna like
you know lots of chicken or lean
proteins lots of fish you always do
whole grains so if we're doing rice
there's always brown rice and always you
know but you know good good serving of
vegetables and just you know nothing
it's always I think the thing that
people you know think about when they
think a private chef you think oh fancy
food but really you're in your home
right so people don't want to feel like
they're in a restaurant and that same is
true in the White House and I think so
we always kept it really really simple
and never never denieth I mean we ate
like everybody else eats nothing nothing
crazy we'd love a good burger you know
so things like that what if
hypothetically you had let's say you
know five years from now you decide you
know what just for the hell of it I'm
gonna have a couple of restaurants in
Chicago and you go back at some point
you're the owner and you decide to kind
of hang out at one of the restaurants
and lo and behold the Obamas come in for
dinner mm-hmm and they say Sam make us
whatever you think will bring back the
memories what would you make them have a
color that bring back the marriage
what would I make them that's a great
question I guess it depends I would say
it depends on what the season is because
I think one of the keys to great food is
cooking with the season summertime
summertime so summer time I'd probably
start with the like a really nice tomato
salad because one of the best things
about cooking the White House has been
the first days Bardon and we got to pick
you know awesome produce right out of
the garden right before dinner so I'd
probably start with an awesome tomato
salad maybe do some barbecued chicken
with with some good spice I don't know
maybe some potatoes and just a bunch of
vegetables so we would click like Sookie
and I do zucchini and basil oh maybe a
little eggplant or some peppers I know
just depends what's going on so we've
grown some gray corn
so maybe do some some really good corn
with that something like that what
what would the tomato salad look like I
love to me if you got great Tomatoes you
don't want to do much job and I think if
you don't have great Tomatoes then you
got to work with them some but you
probably should do a different salad
then I I like it with a little onion and
on this one like typically have a red
onion really thinly sliced one of my big
things I hate particularly sliced red
onion it's like as thin as you can slice
it thinner the better but actually the
tomato side will widen in finally cut to
is good with some nice olive oil and you
know like a white balsamic is really
nice so I'm tomato salad it's got a
touch of sweetness and any any number of
herbs like you know you could do part
holy parsley and some basil maybe throw
in some like green beans or wax beans in
there that are blanched something like
that you know sounds pretty good to me
that sounds great what other pet peeves
do you have aside from overuse of pepper
thickly sliced onions I love pet peeves
I've got a million of them myself so
what what other things make you crazy
when it comes to food I think the thing
that makes me the most crazy and food is
just when people try too hard and they
try to be something that they're not
like there's nothing more than I love
then like a perfect fried wing or like a
awesome burger but I hate when there's
like food that looks all fancy but
tastes like crap like it's like just
just you know if you can do food that's
beautiful and super well composed and
and like I appreciate that too it's not
that I don't like that but if you're
just don't foam everywhere and doing all
some weird concoctions because that's
sort of trendy like I hate the trends in
food I grill just well-executed food
that you can tell it has a lot of love
in it and a lot of authenticity in it
and I think that that for me is its most
important so I I didn't generally that's
the thing that like that determines my
experience in eating and eating
somebody's food that was that was
something that really surprised me when
I got to know
quite a few chefs in reading the 4-hour
chef was that when they came to visit
say my house for dinner or someone else
that's the last thing they wanted to
have was a five-course meal yeah
like the last thing they wanted to have
was some type of foam sprayed onto their
plate with like tweezer cuisine on top
of it they're just like no just give me
like a really fatty burger or yeah
that's something really simple that I
can enjoy consuming uh the what what
made the White House garden unique
because I know that that a lot of
thought went into that and I've become
I've never gardened but I become very
fascinated by it because I when I went
to this this village called og me in
Okinawa at one point has the the longest
median lifespan in the world and I just
noticed that nearly everyone guardant in
some capacity so what made the White
House garden unique well there's a lot
unique about that garden you know one is
the first garden since Eleanor
Roosevelt's Victory Garden during World
War two
which was a really powerful symbolic
garden but it was actually quite small
and really didn't produce food to eat so
the White House garden the first day's
garden is really the first garden since
the late 1890s and that actually produce
food and you know with design this whole
purpose was to really shine a light on
on food where it comes from how it's
grown how hard it is to grow good food
and really like lift up farmers all over
America that are you know producing the
the nourishment that we need to survive
and um and and make it educational and I
and I think that's really you know so it
was a working last garden that we ate
from every day but also we had kids come
down for tours on a weekly basis the
kids would come and plant with the first
lady and then harvest and cook with her
a couple of times a year we had a
compost to really talk about the
importance of getting back to the soil
building soil for fertility which is a
huge issue across the country and we
also had the first ever
beehive on the White House grounds which
which is which is just awesome and we
got tons of honey but also could talk to
the kids about pollinators and why
they're so important and we have a huge
huge problem with pollen colony collapse
disorder and we're losing bees and other
pollinators that you know really
alarming rates which have massive
implications for our economy and our
ability to produce food so you know I
think when you look at the whole picture
and what it's accomplished since that
gardens and planted car gardening across
the country is skyrocket it's up over 30
percent and so it's been really exciting
and and it was just it was a ton of fun
and uh you mentioned you mentioned a
couple of things that I think are really
important the magnitude of the impact of
bee is something I never really
understood and I still need to
understand more but people talk about
the butterfly effect and I know like you
know the bee effect so the ripple the
the cascade of different sort of
ecosystem changes that bees are involved
with is really astonishing the second
thing I would encourage people to look
into is what you mentioned which is the
soil depletion and I remember one point
maybe one of the listeners can confine
this but seeing data that I believe it
was from China that looked at the
incidence and frequency of cancer
diagnosis in different regions in China
and you could pretty much predict how
much cancer there would be based on top
soil depletion that in different regions
because they would end up with trace
mineral deficiencies like selenium and
so on and I remember reading about this
at one point if something like in
certain areas because of mono crops you
know like the wheat and soy and so on in
the US the topsoil is gone from whatever
ten feet to like 10 inches and yeah what
do you think needs to be done or what
can be done to help reverse that trend
so there's there's a lot that needs to
be done and I'd say it's it's a it's a
topic that doesn't get anywhere near the
attention that it deserves but
everything comes everything is based on
the health of our soil it is the reason
why we have such a prosperous nation was
that we had the best soil in the world
and it helped us produce a surplus of
crops which allowed you know big parts
of our population to go on and build and
create and do other things and the
dramatic loss across the nation on on
our on our topsoil is something that is
it couldn't be a more important issue
and it couldn't be a harder one to make
get people excited about cuz I got dirt
like what are you talking about you know
so there's lots of things that need to
be done and I think they're starting to
see some change I think people are
starting to wake up to this we need to
do a much better job at rotating our
crops to rebuild fertility right now
where we're basically growing are just a
couple crops and using synthetic
fertilizers to sort of make up for the
lack of fertility in the soil that's a
problem we're having all kinds of
problems from stemming from that runoff
in our water you know massive algae
blooms in the Gulf killing sea life
there's lots of lots of challenges going
on there so I think we need to rotate
crops I think we need to change our
practices to really focus on rebuilding
that fertility using different sources
of fertilizer natural fertilizers and
you're starting to see people taking
back from that land and rebuilding and
hopefully that will continue to grow and
people I mean I think are gonna
continually have to ask you know work on
you know sourcing food that's coming
from farmers that are you know that's
you know doing those kind of practices
that are are more sustainable I think
the thing that people will realize that
if we use those kind of practices that
is the best one of the best tools we
have to sequester carbon so agriculture
is not only a challenge to when it comes
to sustainability and in our
environmental challenges with with
greenhouse gas emissions it's a it's a
significant producer of but it's
actually unlike other aspects of the
challenge it can actually be part of the
solution and so there's there's there's
exciting opportunity there that we don't
see in too many other sectors that need
to change yeah I'm I'm excited about the
potential for kind of soil replenishment
because I
like it could be effective in marketing
product does that make sense like
there's a there's a kind of economic
self-interest that I think could be
harnessed if somebody could create the
proper campaign what what do you see or
what do you think the future is if any
of say organic subsidies for people who
really want to are large companies that
really want to produce organic produce
but view it as cost prohibitive or
something along those lines yeah so this
is obviously a very complicated a
complicated question and a really
complicated politics I think the place
and this again is hard to get people
super excited about but I think the
place to really start is in research so
over the last about 50 years we poured
the vast majority I mean you know
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars into
researching just a couple crops and
fruits and vegetables writ large have
not gotten mostly it's gone to corn and
soy some wheat but mostly corn and soy
and that is a loud corn and soy to be
produced much more efficiently than it
used to and so a lot of the price
difference we talked about like the
relative cost of say sugar and other
things versus fruit or vegetable it is
because we figured out how to grow those
crops much more efficiently and so if we
invest that same kind of research to try
to figure out how to grow fruits and
vegetables more efficiently we're gonna
make up a lot of the ground now part of
the challenge is that you know the
people who are currently growing say the
fruits and vegetables
no matter whether they're doing an
organic or not organic the they like the
fact that they're the only ones growing
it so they not support subsidies for
other people to grow more fruits oh
that's interesting
so there's really tough politics because
in Washington if the people you're
trying to help are against you it's
gonna be very hard to move anything
through it's hard to move anything
through if they're with you because
there's always been people people on the
other side fighting very hard and
investing a lot of money and seeing that
not happen so on this particular one it
the politics are really hard to get
Congress to shift we're we're
putting some of these substances now on
the organic side which is a different
set of questions I think the markets
gonna have to continue to drive the
change and you're seeing organic you
know continue to grow at a very rapid
rate although it's a still a very small
part of the overall food economy but I
think the more consumers demand it I
think the more it's gonna get grown and
it's going to become increasingly more
affordable for farmers to produce it
when we get some more scale there yeah
it's it's a such a thorny gnarly topic
and I would I would suggest just as a
side note for folks who perhaps want to
eat organic but have to pick and choose
for financial reasons or otherwise
there's a list called the Dirty Dozen
and I think it might be the clean
fifteen which is sort of the the twelve
items produce items that are best
avoided that have the highest
concentrations of pesticides but I think
the research is really as you noted
super important because if it's one
thing in the abstract to say organics
better for reasons a B and C and
avoiding synthetic pesticides but if
someone could actually look at say the
the endocrine impact of estrogenic
compounds that are found in synthetic
fertilizers so that therefore affect
fertility or whatever then I think the
it could get more air time
I will say just on one thing on this
point though you know I think people
should try to eat organic when they can
but I think they need to eat fruits and
vegetables first and foremost so I think
part of the thing to be concerned about
is well I would much rather people eat
conventional any conventional fruit or
vegetable than like organic chips or
organic cupcakes right and and I think
you know I we're getting better people
are raising more awareness our
agricultural practices are getting
better largely because this is getting
more and more expensive so farmers are
learning how to be more diligent about
their applications there's obviously a
lot longer to go but there's going to be
some things where we're going to need
some insecticides and some pesticides
and I think that's okay as long as
they're being used responsibly
but but I don't want people I think part
of thing we need to avoid is sort of
fear-based if you eat this it's going to
kill you because there's just not the
evidence there there there's there's
reason for serious concern and and
continued engagement and pushing on on
some of these topics but but it
shouldn't keep anybody from from
consuming that kind of that balanced
diet that that we know is important do
you so there was an article that came
out recently by Steve Case called the
future Buddhist food
what do you what is your what are your
thoughts on meal replacements like
Soylent and so yeah so I actually
tweeted about I tweeted about that
article I couldn't agree with Steve more
I mean Steve basically makes the
argument that sort of high-tech art of
like artificially put together drinks
that you know are based on some science
you know kind of could replace food and
I think the vision for the folks at Sue
Ellen is that they can create a perfect
meal
so instead of eating a bunch of junk you
can just conveniently drink this so I I
don't I don't hate the sort of the
vision there in the sense that they're
trying to do something good but if the
future is a disgusting tasteless
soulless beverage just a stain you know
just to keep us alive that's not a
future I have much interest in being a
part of I think I think it lacks
authenticity I think it lacks flavor I
think it lacks happiness and joy
and all of that goes into what a good
good nourishment means to me and I think
I see a role but maybe with elderly
people and others for improved sort of
dietary supplement you know meals like
that but I don't think that's a solution
that I for one have any interest in
participating in I think real good food
grown properly that supports the people
who are growing it that supports the
hell the people who are eating it that
also is damn good is where we should all
be you know driving for yeah I've done
an about-face on this stuff because I've
always been a kind of supplement addict
and been infatuated with pills and
potions and whatnot as a supplementation
but I mean there's they're called
supplements for a reason and I've really
found that echoing the sentiment of
saying Nassim Taleb ruh at the Black
Swan and Aunty fragile so he uses a term
called epistemological or yeah pista
logical arrogance which is
overestimating how much you understand
about anything is a human and I think
it's it's naive to think I've come to
this conclusion anyway that you can that
we would understand every element of
what's in an Apple for instance or what
in a slice of ribeye like we we just
there's so much uncharted territory that
it's naive to think we could take the
four or five things we've isolated put
them in a pill and and sort of confer
the same nutritional benefit for
instance I mean that's kind of point
number one but yeah it's it's very
interesting it's a it's very very
fascinating subject but I've I've gone
completely in the in the whole food
direction just trying to consume a
spectrum of colors every day for
instance the so can I want to add some
of that yeah I think that is on the
nutritional side that that basic point
understanding of our limitations
couldn't be more right
I mean we've tried very hard to kind of
reduce our health to one vitamin or
fiber or this or that in a very
reductionist way and utterly miss the
interplay between all of these different
vitamins nutrients fiber protein and
also by the way completely miss how our
body processes so it's turning out that
you know we have a hundred trillion
bacteria in our gut 100 trillion which
really what we're doing is feeding that
bacteria which then in turn feeds us and
it's gonna the evidence is emerging that
the microbiome that the gut bacteria is
going to be one of the most important
things to focus on in terms of improving
our hell
and that we've lost quite a bit of
diversity in our gut and we don't but
there's you know a couple hundred
species of bacteria are got a little
less and we are just trying to figure
out what does what and how they interact
and it's everybody is different the
complexities here are just overwhelming
we know that they need to be fed a high
diet of fiber lots of fruits and
vegetables basically what they feed and
from birth so like we for a long time
there is parts of breast milk that we
that babies couldn't digest and we
didn't understand we didn't think they
were important but turns out actually
all those elements in breast milk are
feeding the emerging biome and the young
and the babies got which is then gives
it a it deals with the immune system and
inflammation all these vital things and
and digesting of food so there's like
the complexity is beyond anything that
we can comprehend right now and I think
we've continually like we're over and
over try to say was oh it's fat is the
problem and like turns out okay wait
that's not the problem oh it's a
deficiency in omega this so now okay
well it turns out well that's good but
it's not certainly the panacea that we
was made out to be yeah every time we do
this we get it wrong and so I I agree
with you I mean I think there's some
things that have been tested over the
millennia and which is that kind of
balance good diet of you know whole
grains and lots of fruits and vegetables
lean proteins and I think that's where
we were safest is when we stay in that
kind of that kind of space and I'm glad
you mentioned safest because it's it's
not just oops I didn't cover all my
bases when you take a very reductionist
approach for instance when people when
the media got its hands on the so-called
promises of beta carotene that people
start consuming massive amounts of beta
carotene in isolation it can actually
cause a lot of problems we're not sort
of consuming it in its natural
environment so to speak but I'd love to
shift gears and ask some some rapid for
our questions they don't have to have
rapid answers but when you think of the
word successful who is the first person
who comes to mind and why mmm
well two people come to mind well Barack
Obama and my and my father but four
wildly different reasons
I mean Barack Obama's you know success
to me I measure based on impact and the
amount of impact that somebody's trying
to have in a positive way on the world
around and not by money or but it's sort
of what you do with the places you've
been given and you know I'm there's lots
of legitimate disagreements and in
politics and I'm sure there's legitimate
disagreements with some of the things
that the president has has done but he
is you know I know firsthand on a daily
basis that here's somebody who's trying
to and it has had a massive positive
impact on the world around him so that
that's something that you know I I very
much had look up to and admire and and
you know in mice much much much smaller
way try to figure out how I can have the
the biggest positive impact on the world
around me and I'd say but on the flip
side you know but that takes you know
there's a lot of ambition that goes with
that and I'll you know disappointments
when you fail on the flip side like
success that my father is um he is a
he's a fifth grade teacher has he just
retired after 25 years he lives an
incredibly humble life and you know it's
a you know a union guy growing up and
and and and a teacher and a union guy in
serve in the school and he he he's
utterly content he has a good community
of friends he's you know has roof
overhead and and and meals on his table
in fact when I first looked at a
restaurant in Chicago he had never spent
$20 on a meal for himself which I only
found out when I invited him in for a
meal at the end of my summertime there
and so he's just very content in in like
the simple pleasures and the sort of a
simple life and I and that's something
that is you know I I also try to take
into what success looks like is is is
that kind of content this and being
appreciative of what you have right
having the
not just the drive for achievement yep
what's what book or what is a book that
you've gifted most often or gifted very
often to other people mmm gift and I've
been pushing around the art of fielding
over the last year or two bye Chad
Harbach I love that book it's like it's
it's so it's a baseball theme but it's
really about life and and all that goes
with that and complexities of
relationships and I don't know there's
something that book just sucked me in
and and it I love the feeling of being
sucked in which you know doesn't happen
with that intensity too often so I was a
good one the art of fielding are there
any any documentaries documentary films
or movies that have sucked you in in
that way mm-hmm I love documentaries I'm
a big fan and a good and a great movie
as well the last one I just saw actually
just came out which I really loved
called just eat it and it's about food
waste
well we waste 40% of the food we produce
which is just insane there's no other
majors like life system that is so
inefficient and then it's about this
couple that basically for I forget how
long six months decides to only eat food
that they has been wasted that they find
thrown away in some way shape or form
and it's unbelievable story it's so
really well done it's only an hour I
think just aired on MSNBC actually but
they they are having to have to give
away food they find so much of it they
can't eat it all
and it so it was very powerful very well
done but that's the one that's top of
mind off to check that out that makes me
think there's a book I read a long time
ago I think it was called the man who
gave up money or the man who stopped
using money something along those lines
but it delves into sort of the
dumpster-diving freegan movement I guess
they call them instead of vegans really
fast anything yeah what what hundred
dollar or less purchase has had the
biggest positive impact on your life in
the last six months to a year let's just
whatever comes to mind doesn't have to
be in that timeframe yeah the recent
purchased I got a I got a Kindle
recently which I hadn't had before which
has been great you know I know people
I'm like way being you know behind the
curve and not the highest tech way to
read a read it read things but it's but
it's been great because I'm all over the
place and in so that's helps I also got
an ice bucket and it's made the Rose aid
that much colder as summer starting to
hit and that's been oh an investment
well worth while that's a good call ice
bucket yeah love rose a there's a great
you know I grew up on Long Island
there's a wonderful rose a from Wolfer
estates yeah yeah I know that it's
really good
yeah the winemaker Roman is just amazing
not too expensive either
what what does the first 60 minutes of
your day look like do you what what are
morning rituals weather when you were at
the White House or now that have been
consistent for yeah so pretty consistent
basic routine the one variable and that
like I used to do a lot more I don't do
anymore like the first thing I love to
do from the perfect girl is to do a
short stint of meditation for like 10 or
15 minutes it's been hard for me to keep
that impossible for me to do that the
White House for whatever reason I just
think mentally quieting and slowing my
mind was just something that just it
wouldn't do it's hard I tried and
exhaustion also played a role but I wake
up and work out five or six days a week
do about 30 minutes of cardio and then
two weights of various sort of sets and
what type of cardio did you so I'll do
10 minutes on the bike and then now I'm
been doing like 12 minute you know
interval interval run run and then I'm
doing like another 10 minutes in Inked
like 12 incline walking at 3.5 on a
treadmill sometimes I do the elliptical
I'm in there and then and then do
weights
and then and then so in the White House
it was always you know take a shower get
ready and then I do
oatmeal a banana and coffee since I've
been out of the White House I've been
doing eggs one of you know a couple ways
some of my cold we toast with maybe some
avocado a little salmon and then and
coffee that's been the routine and then
away I go
do you do it do you do anything in
particular before bed mmm I don't have
that same kind of routine at night
all thing cuz night there's like much
more variable like the morning has
always been the time that I take for
myself and carve out because after that
it's like anybody's guess what's gonna
happen but try to you know try to come
and bring down a little bit but often
times and certainly the White House I
was working till 1:00 to 3:00 in the
morning pretty consistently so there's
sort of like you worked til you fell off
just fell off your chair I call it to
bed and then got up a few hours later
and started doing it all over again
so so I don't have that thing kind of
night we changed ganas and when you when
you meditated what type of meditation
did you do what did that what did that
look like so I so I the the woman who
taught me was one of the most amazing
people I've ever known
she was an 80 year old woman who was
actually from France who I met when I
was traveling on the border of Malaysia
and Thailand on an overnight train she
was 80 years old and she had spent the
last like 20 plus years or her life just
traveling with a teeny little for like
eight pound backpack and that's all she
had and she went everywhere and she was
just the most amazing person and she so
it's like a you know but she's not like
a you know formal teacher so you know
just trying to sit up you know have good
posture and just wrote you know
fundamentally relax and focus on my
breathing it's like it's sophisticated
as I got and trying to let your mind
relax and and repeating that forcing
your mind to get back to that state
which is you know it's um
and such a challenge is so hard as as
sort of how I would do it for as long as
I guess I could but when I do it it
feels so much better and so much more
grounded and then sort of calm through
the day it's uh but it takes a lot of
discipline it's carve out the time in
any given day I thought yeah I found for
myself because I meditate 15 to 20
minutes each morning and usually 22
things really interesting number one it
takes about 15 minutes for me just to
let the dust in them or the mud settle
so I really only feel like I'm
meditating in the calm sense for the
last five minutes but it's you need I
need the 15 minutes just as a warm-up or
clear that may be and then secondly that
posture I've noticed if I just sit with
very good posture and kind of lengthen
my spine imagine my head being kind of
pulled up on a string even if I don't
get to some sublime state if I just
focus and sit that way for 20 minutes
there's a huge benefit for me anyway I
oh sit about that yep I would love to
ask some questions from people on
Facebook and Twitter we're very excited
that we were gonna be chatting the first
is a tough one but it's from Andrew
Zimmern I love that man he's off
andrew's great that also has been on the
podcast and he wanted to ask some
questions because he hears them very
often he gets asked them very often and
it's always curious how other people
answer them so the first is if it's
illegal to sell cigarettes to minors or
drugs / booze why do we let fast-food or
sugar drinks into schools yeah so great
question so a couple points so one
because of the new standards that are in
play there are no more sugary drinks in
schools and those are out and I actually
need to give the you know the beverage
companies credit they actually
voluntarily voluntarily pulled out most
of those beverages around starting in
around 2007 but the new standards
utterly eliminate all sugary drinks you
can have a low calorie in high school
you can have a low calorie Gatorade and
you can
no calorie jinxo diet sodas are allowed
in high schools not in middle schools
and certainly not in lower schools so
those drinks are out on the fast-food
side I have always been pretty appalled
that some of these particularly less
healthy companies have set up shop in
high schools now this is not ubiquitous
by any stretch of the imagination but
they definitely exist in some number and
I actually need to look and see because
their food does not meet the standards
so unless they're changing their
offerings so I am not sure how many like
where where they are in the evolution of
either what they're offering in schools
or if some of them have had to pull out
you know the truth is I don't know the
answer that but I'll dig into that and
come back to you on it but I agree I
think it's really inappropriate to be
serving you know have a fast-food pretty
unhealthy restaurant set up in a in a
high school I find that to be I've
always found that to be very off-putting
cool yeah would love for people
listening who participate on the blog
obviously there'll be a post with all
the links and resources and so on
including things like you know
organizations like American Farmland
trust that have done stuff with if you
want to get involved with some of these
things but I would love to hear ideas
for what types of campaigns or angles
could be taken to remedy that from folks
I do pay attention to the comments next
question is from cinema air this is on
Twitter best the use of wine that's too
old to drink so you know depending on
the kind of wine and you know I think
there's there's probably a little magic
depending on where you are and how it
goes but you know that's how you make
vinegar so you know grape juice turns
into vinegar right so there you could
depending on how codes you can use it
kind of in that in that way a lot of
people use it for cooking but you know
no no real chef would say you should if
it's not good to drink whether it's
really not good to cook with so the
truth is like there's uh there's not
much to do with it I got to be honest I
would get at least not that I know I'm
sure maybe somebody out there has got a
good thing but basically like drink it
before it goes bad as my best advice to
you and you know the thing that you know
if you get just one of those simple air
pumps with with the with a rubber top
that pulls the air out you add you know
a week or two depending on the wine life
to it and that's what I use you know we
use that in our house and it makes a big
difference so there's nothing worth
there's like one of the worst feelings
in the world is dumping out a half a
bottle of wine that you didn't get to
finish yeah I Payne the the vacuum is
really cheap and really effective I use
the same device on that point Stefan I
think it's Stefan Bendel what should
home chefs stop doing so wasting wine
would be one Wow what should home chefs
stop doing there's there's a few things
what should home chefs or do I need to
spend more time with home chefs to give
you the best answer I think dragging the
knife across the cutting board like as
like a shovel it's something that like
you never supposed to do if you need to
like move like the vegetables will scoop
them up use the backside of the knife
but like scraping the knife on the
cutting board just drives me crazy it's
just really bad for your knife dulls it
immediately something that I cringe at I
think chefs the home cooks need to work
with heat I would not be afraid of heat
more so particularly when you're sharing
fish so you need that pan hot and so
letting like putting it in like getting
your pan super hot and then putting your
fish down and leaving it and not
touching it and letting it get that nice
you know good sear good golden brown on
it before you touch it it's like key to
fish and most most people don't get
their pan hot enough don't heat it don't
ever get it out enough don't take the
time to heat it and then play around
with the fish which which ends up really
hurting it's it's open it feel but I
think allowing I think they the one
thing that's the big difference between
a pro and a home cook is that like
to see the getting real color on things
be it meat or any vegetable that's on
the grill or anything you're putting in
the pan I just let it go when you think
it's like ready like give it another
minute or two and like get that really
dark dark color on it it adds a ton of
flavor
when can you tell that your pan is hot
enough for that nice sear on a fish so
like when you put the oil in like you
don't want it to immediately start
smoking like then your oil is done like
don't put it in there if it's like you
put it in it's like smoke but like you
should see the oil get that kind of
those lines in it that kind of shimmer
and it should just start to give off a
little bit of like you can see a little
bit of smoke then that's when your
you're ready to go
but it should be like hot like when you
put it in a backpack like it should be
like go crazy like if it's just like a
little mild bubble like you're not you
weren't ready and what what type of oil
do you like to use with with fish for
instance you know you can use a lot like
you can use olive oil it has a lower
smoke point but you can you can get away
with it
I like grapeseed oil is a great oil to
cook with you know you can do high heat
canola is totally fine those are
probably the main ones to go with you
can it oil is awesome yeah yeah I've
been playing myself a little bit with
avocado oil because it has highly you
know make a three content decent smoke
point but it's so rich yes you can some
cut depending on the food you either
enhance or completely contaminate what
your going to trying to make next
question is from Kaos Sonata when you
fall into a rut in the kitchen what book
resource or person do you turn to for
inspiration Oh interesting so I don't
yeah I mean I try to get out and eat or
go to the store or go like see and feel
and touch and smell is the thing that I
try to do when I'm when I'm just sort of
filled dead and used the actual
ingredients to inspire what I'm gonna do
but I think the book that I wrote that I
look at
I really don't look at cookbooks that a
ton anymore but the one recently that I
have is all of auto lane gates but
awesome how do you oh wait a second here
I know this name how do you spell that
name or the first name um a little leg
at OTT Oh Ellie and let me let me just
pull it out for you
Oh TT Oh Ellie and GHI he is an
incredible chef him and his partner
actually one is he's you know they're
Palestinian and Israeli team couple and
they have plenty as their most famous
book but they have Jerusalem and plenty
more their books are just spectacular
and the recipes are simple but so
delicious III definitely cooked a few
out of them and they're always they're
always awesome if someone is new to
healthy cooking where would you suggest
they start what could they start with as
that huh yeah and anything simple they
could they could use to get the ball
rolling in terms of like a dish dish
stocking the kitchen unn stocking the
kitchen it was it's it's a general
question yeah I'd say you can interpret
it any way you want so I think the key
is like starting simple I think people
whenever they approach like okay I wanna
make a change they think I got an
overhaul everything and so then they try
to do a dramatic thing and then and then
of course it's not sustainable you can't
keep that up but you revert back to kind
of who you've been and it then you just
completely stop so I would think like
little things so one place to start just
vinegar if you want to start small like
getting really good vinegar makes us
like a salad go from really uninspired
to really delicious so one place that I
did actually invest a little you're
gonna invest a little resource in is
getting some really nice vinegar to make
really beautiful salads and salads are
like some some some kind of green like a
good combo is some kind of some kind of
leaf some kind of texture be a cucumber
fennel or you know various things
acidity so you could add you know any
kind of citrus fruit there's always
great or just a really nice vinegar some
nuts of some kind and a cheese or some
kind like
Parmesan or pecorino or different if you
like that kind of basic components it's
hard to really make it terrible
sometimes cheese can throw you off so
you you know play around with that but
you get good texture you get good flavor
and if you have a nice vinegar like the
world is yours and that's a really good
place to just add some salad and you
know to your dinner is a is a great
place to start but I would just try to
add a piece of fruit try to add it
another thing of vegetables at dinner
like if you just start there those two
things and I think the other main thing
to start is drinking more water there's
nothing better than water the more water
you drink the less you know sugary
beverages you're gonna drink which is
you know really key if you're going to
try to live a healthier life and you
know that that's a great place to start
and then from there you can you build
from that yellow water just to echo that
for people who might be following a diet
of any types low carb paleo whatever to
try to lose fat if your liver is
burdened by even partial dehydration
it's just not going to do a very good
job of helping you to love you know
oxidized fat so I've noticed
tremendously even with getting into say
ketosis I'm experimenting with that more
water I drink the more I walk the better
off I am the faster I'll drop in to say
ketosis but the other thing just on your
point with nuts and cheese if if it
seems like with almost any dish if
someone wants to impress a dinner guest
just put parmesan and sliced almonds on
anything and it looks like that
it looks really fancy and it tastes
amazing yeah and on that note this is
will McClellan there may not be a best
meal but what's the best meal to impress
a girl with but it's easy to make this
is I'm sure a question this is guys have
a phobia a lot of guys of cooking in any
capacity so what would be a signal that
might impress a girl but that is easy to
make that's funny
well I was just talking to one of my
best friends in fact that guy who was
with me in Vienna
and then and he was telling me about a
date he was on just yesterday and he was
saying oh yeah I cooked that risotto
again I you know he's like man you tell
me that at one time and I grow with that
for the last ten years I think a risotto
is a really good very easy dish to make
that that you can do a lot of things
with that seems very fancy and
impressive but isn't that hard basic
risotto is you start you know start with
like an onion or shallot you cook that
down you cook your rice you have a stock
of some kind so you can buy a nice
chicken stock or vegetable yeah seafood
stock depending what you're going to put
in there and make sure that's hot and
then you're just adding some stock as
you go and you so sorry onions and then
you put the rice to mix it around a
little white wine and let that evaporate
and then you're just adding stock as you
go until the rice is like done you want
it to be a little you know al dente you
want to be a little have a little tooth
to it so you don't want it mushy and
then you just finish it with whatever
you want if you're gonna have like some
scallops in there you can do a whole
seafood thing you can do a lamb risotto
you could you can do a vegetable risotto
you can do anything you want it's hard
to mess it up because you finish it with
a little butter or some olive oil and a
bunch of Parmesan cheese so like it's
like hard to go wrong there and it's
sort of one of those dishes that it's
hard to make it perfect but it's it's
it's easy to make it good easy to make
it good oh god that's so true for so
many things in life right so I want to
get a little granular on this cuz I'd
actually like to try to make it this
weekend so you know you you take the
onions or the shallots Azure pretty
thinly sliced right you want to dice
those dice you want to make them you
know very small dice like a mint got it
and then you throw that in the pan or
pot I guess pot in this case with some
like olive oil and you just would you
have olive oil you would you have some
type of oil in there to start with yeah
yep so you have some olive oil you put
that in you cook it a little bit then
you put in your rice and you know you
depending on how many people you have
you know cup a cup to two cups you know
if you're not doing a ton you know a cup
of rice should probably be enough if
it's too
people will be enough for two people
then you cook that a little bit get that
covered and coated and then you add you
know a bit of white wine now the stock
is the stock already in there
the stocks not in there stocks should be
in a separate separate pot and it should
you should it should be hot you should
bring that to a boil and keep that warm
got it okay so onions then cook that
down let it kind of caramelize a little
bit color on it you don't want color
okay and then you then you add the rice
then you add so you have a cup of rice
how much white wine would you put in
there
yeah I'm not I'm not a great recipe guy
like you just want to get a nice like
couple splashes in there like no that's
fine I know maybe like a quarter cup
okay at the most and then you you cook
that down so you want when you when you
know you're you want to get rid of all
the alcohol so you know that like when
you lean over the potty you kind of put
the what's evaporating kind of you you
put your nose over that if it kind of
burns the inside of your nose you know
that they're still alcohol burning off
and like once that sort of burning
sensation comes and it's just like okay
that smells good then you know you're
you're ready to go it should be pretty
dry it should be dry basically before
you then start adding your stock got it
and then how long once you add the stock
is the this sort of cocktail is it on
like a medium heat or what's the heat
yeah so you want it to be a nice simmer
uncovered simmer and you only use a
wooden spoon because you don't want to
damage the rice and you only want to use
a boreal rice really important which is
a nice starchy rice so you'll get a good
a nice starchy kind of broth and so when
you so yeah so you just add the stock as
you go so you cook it you know it'll
start a drawer being you guys okay I'll
need some more you start absorbing you
keep adding and now if you run out of
stock you can finish with water no
problem you know you want to heat the
water up you don't want to put in a cold
liquid into your risotto because that
stops all the cooking process and can
start breaking down the rice over if you
do that too much this idea I'm gonna try
this this weekend because it seems like
you could also for instance with like
scallops which are so dis
acceptably easy to cook yeah you can
kind of muck around with the risotto and
if you're kind of flying by the seat of
your pants and half screwing it up
since the scallops only take whatever
you know four minutes two minutes to
cook you can kind of do it last minute
and just drop them in yeah so for like
if you're using the base cups the little
guy it's like basically when your
risotto is basically done or just yeah
you put them in you just give it a stir
and turn it off and like they'll
basically cook through just as it
settles because you want you'll want so
at the end so you cook it it's getting
close it whenever you're done so like
bateman it's basically done and then you
put in your parmesan you put in some
butter you put in a little olive oil and
you give that a good stir you're gonna
want to let it just rest for a minute
and it'll kind of come together if it
dries up like when you put it on the
plate you wanted to just kind of relax
onto the plate like you don't want to
hold up and kind of a ball you don't
want to run either so you may need to
add a little stock to make it you know
should feel like it's got a little sauce
but it's not saucy right and but then
you can literally add whatever you want
any kind of herbs any flavor profile
that you like like if I love basil
asparagus and and zucchini I can add
that at the end let that basically warm
up and you guys just have a beautiful
risotto if you're doing scallops I love
like a lemon seafood risotto so you can
add a bunch of lemon juice a ton of
lemon Jeff but zest like lots of lemon
zest maybe a squeeze of a lemon and say
shrimp and scallops and and tarragon
it's a great herb for that one killer
risotto so you can that one will impress
any any lady whoever whoever I'm going
to try that this Saturday
a question from Kerry Kaminski what dish
have you most frequently made for
houseguests Wow most dish frequent most
frequently made I don't know the answer
to that to be honest to you I mean I
love the grill I'm a just a grill freak
it's super simple less dishes and
biggest flavor so I throw everybody when
it's warm I throw everything on the girl
I grow all the vegetables like I we grow
eggplant we girl like rapini
pepper zucchini I just it just all goes
up there and took its really healthy way
to cook cause you're using very little
you don't need much you know there's no
heavy fats or anything and I've been
doing pork chops up there some steak
even pieces of fish depending on what it
is shrimp so I don't know I just I just
try to keep it fun and simple I think
though the one thing is it's actually
kind of reminds me I think the one other
difference between home cooks and and
pros is this acidity level like at when
you think it's ready like add another
lemon yes totally
we always but like pros bump up the the
acidity level which is what it's like
one of those like one of the secrets
just we add a little more acid and it
makes everything taste better yeah seems
like pros use lemon juices as they might
use salt okay at the time yeah up what
are some of the mistakes that people
make with grilling what do they make
with grilling one the grills not hot so
they end up not getting very good collar
- I think that's the that's the main
mistake I think they also like play with
food - like when you throw it on there
like let it go let it get that nice
color and before you start moving around
and you know I think grills are best
when you get to sear but like if you're
doing a piece of meat or even a piece of
fish letting it finish in the oven even
just for a minute or two depending on
how big your piece of of meat is is the
best way to do it because it'll cook
more evenly a lot of times if you're
using a really hot grill you'll get like
a lot of well-done and then like a
little bit of rare or medium rare in the
middle
but like the sides will be super dry and
tough so if you get a really hot grill
get a great sear you'll lock the flavor
and then you finish in the oven it's
always the best way to do it yeah - to
avoid the black and blue steak yeah next
question is from Daniel lawhon what is
the best way to systematically develop
and refine your palate and I'll just
I'll modify that and say what is what is
one simple way to start systematically
developing and refining your palate
Wow that's an interesting question I
never Tate I've never I've never asked
that I I think um I think basically just
tasting everything you possibly can and
really tasting is like thinking about it
like breaking down the flavor and just
paying attention to it smelling things
so smell is a really fundamental part of
taste way more than we realize
so I would you know make sure you're
really smelling touching and tasting as
much as you possibly can eat at
restaurants go to farmers markets try
things out and the more you taste like
the more you'll start understanding the
subtleties and complexities like I don't
know I don't know a resource I mean
that's just the way I learned it's like
cooking and tasting things and that's
the way most chefs learn I don't know of
a resource that's like a guide to palate
development I'm sure there's something
out there but I don't I don't know of it
yeah it's a it this was a this was a
question I had to tackle for myself when
I was attempting to learn to cook in the
beginning so I would I would say to
Daniel a couple things really help me
the first was going to restaurants going
to the same restaurant
say five days in a row and maybe you
can't do five days but going there
regularly enough on off days like
Tuesday to Thursday Monday to Thursday
to get to know the staff always keeping
the menu with you when you're eating so
you can you can read along as you eat
dishes so you know what's in it like the
five or six seven ingredients whatever
it might be smelling your food before
you eat it it looks kind of weird but
it's smelling food before you because
I've I've always had chronic side well
up until I started using kind of sinus
rinses I had chronic sinusitis and I had
a lot of trouble smelling and then last
thing would be for unfamiliar
ingredients that are mixed into a dish
and this is part of the reason that you
would go during the week asking them to
give you a little bit on the side so
that you can taste it individually
before you eat it in the mix I found and
there's there's a fun book called the
flavor Bible also then oh yeah that is a
cool book and a lot of chefs use that to
come up with unusual flavor combinations
next question is from Abe Diaz if you
had to pack the essence of life into a
burrito what would that burrito be like
the essence of life into a burrito yeah
yeah meaning like what would the
ingredients be yeah food ingredients
yeah Wow all right here we go
okay I think I would have you'd have you
know you'd have some brown rice in there
for like fortitude sustenance for like
you know your grit determination I would
have avocado lots of avocado for like
the richness of life beauty color flavor
like excitement I would have would be my
protein I definitely have beans
I think beans are like this you know the
see their growth and they stay they they
harness promise for me hope you know
opportunity optimism I'd have a little
maybe a little skirt steak for strength
and but not a lot and I'd have a
habanero salsa for like the spice the
excitement the you know so the in being
vigorous part of what makes life so
amazing and then maybe I'd let the chef
throw in one other mystery ingredient to
stimulate curiosity which i think is the
most important or underappreciated
quality of of people who lives great
successful awesome lives which is just
just like being curious about the world
around them so I let that I let the chef
throw a mystery a mystery ingredient air
has that I love it it looks like looks
like my cheat day
on Saturday is going to be risotto
burritos if just two more questions this
is this is really fun and people can
certainly let us know if if they want
more more Sam I'm sure a lot of people
will the the two two more questions for
you but the first is if you could give
your let's just say give yourself advice
when you were just graduating from you
Chicago
well what advice would that be wow it's
a great question um well I'll probably
give myself advice when I graduated from
when I went in what it said study a
little harder you know work a little
harder but I when I left I mean I I
think advice that I that that I live by
which it kind of holds which is
basically get out there in the world be
open to it explore it be don't don't
don't worry about having a clear plan
because I didn't know enough to have a
clear plan and you know follow things
that I really cared about and go all in
when I when I found something that that
interests me because passion like
passion is an overstated word I mean I
think passion develops so like I was
really into food and was interested in
it and I threw myself into into food but
I I it didn't become a passion til I can
you know really combined although I was
like passionate about it it wasn't a
life passion until I can like combined
you know food and nourishment with
health and sustainability and politics
and policy and what we're doing to
really help make sure that all people
can live healthy productive you know
awesome lives through the food that
they're eating I think that's what sort
of became that that passion so I think a
lot of people are like find your passion
I think passion comes from a combination
of being open curious of really going
all in and you find something that that
you're interested in then then that then
that goes alright and I think always
just trying to figure out how to do the
right thing you know trying to remember
why you're doing what you're doing is
are kind of the lessons that I've tried
to
led by and and and they they've served
well on the you know getting out in the
world gives you a perspective on
wherever you are that I found to be
transformative and and just a foundation
of Who I am so it's been it's been good
no I I really want to underscore
something you said that I think is
really important and that is just
related to finding your passion a lot of
people ask me how how can I find my
passion and I think that in their mind
they see this singular thing that is
this lightning bolt that knocks them off
their feet and in my case just like you
it was an unexpected combination of
things that came together by trying a
lot of things and being not having in my
case I didn't have like a five or ten
year plan but it was I will do the best
I can at this this next gig whatever
that is and look for doors that open and
so I don't want people to think to feel
like and I've seen people reflect this
feel like a failure because they they
haven't had a single activity hit them
like a you know Cupid's arrow or
whatever what if you could make one
asked of the people listening to this
what would that ask me oh great question
one asked I think my one asked would
just be to to be engaged I think right
now we're suffering from lack and
engagement around some of the issues
that really matter and you know there's
lots of solutions there's lots of
different ways to think about it
particularly in food I think you know
there's you know there's nothing more
important than making sure our kids are
getting food I mean we have so many
hungry kids and in in the country we're
wasting so much food we're not getting
enough nourishing food and the face of
climate change there's gonna be it's
gonna be even harder to grow healthy
food and produced it at an affordable
and an affordable price for people so
the challenges are higher and allow us
so I mean so engaging and caring and
trying to improve the food system
through the choices that we're making
every day there's a start and I think
for people who really get into it it's
starting to
translate that into and into politics
and actually caring about these issues
in terms of who's representing us in
Washington and I think that's a the
politicians follow the people and
businesses follow the people like they
try to like shape decisions and they
mark it etcetera but in the end they're
following and so we need to lead and
then we're leading every single day in
ways that sometimes we're aware of and
sometimes that we're not and so I think
that kind of awareness and engagement
can have a profound impact on what
companies are producing and what
policies are being made so I think
that's my big ask at least in my in my
world but the truth is that that kind of
same same principle applies to just
about any issue and I think we just the
more were engaged the more our democracy
works
agreed yeah give a damn people don't be
apathetic find it find something to get
it get excited about and care about ah
Sam where can people find you on the
Internet where can people find you on
Twitter I guess you're at chef Sam Kass
yeah yep at chef Sam Kass Instagram is
Sam Kass DC Facebook to be honest yeah I
said that up so long ago I don't even
know what my name is I have to look that
up the master of this Wow you know I'm
fumbling my way through all the all the
interwebs one day at a time I do have a
website where people can can also check
you out
no not yet that is in the works Jim
process will process I will I will share
that with people when it is ready for
for its big debut
Sam well this is this is great I really
enjoy hanging out this was a lot of fun
and for people listening you can check
out the links to resources books
mentioned etc in the show notes and
those show notes and the show notes for
every other podcast are which is a four
hour workweek comm forward slash podcast
but seven thank you so much for the time
tim has been awesome in your
you're the best in your you're helping
people live better lives and it's it was
I'm gonna be here with you now thanks
buddy I'll talk to you soon
all right take care this episode is
brought to you by 99designs your
one-stop shop for all things graphic
design related I've used 99designs for
everything from banner ads to book
covers including sketches and mock-ups
that led to the 4-hour body which later
became number one york times number one
Wall Street Journal and the brainstorm
and a lot of it took place with
designers from around the world and
here's how it works whether you need a
t-shirt a business card a website and
app thumbnail whatever it might be you
submit that project and designers from
around the world will send you sketches
and mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash temp
this podcast is brought to you by vision
and main don't worry about the spelling
all you need to know is this I have
organized my entire life around avoiding
fancy shirts because you have to iron
them you sweat through them they smell
really easily they're a pain in the ass
mizzen and maine has given me the only
shirt that i need and what I mean by
that and Kelly Starrett loves these
shirts as well is that you can trick
people they look really fancy so you can
take them out to nice dinners whatever
but they're made from athletic sweat
wicking material so you can throw this
thing into your luggage in a heap or on
your kitchen table like I did recently
and then pull it out throw it on with no
ironing no steaming no nothing walk out
and you could probably wear this thing
for a week straight or make it your only
dress shirt and take it on trips for
weeks at a time never wash it it will
not smell you will not sweat through it
you got to check these things out so go
to 4-hour workweek comm all spelled out
for our work week com forward slash
shirts check it out for our work week
comm forward slash shirts and you'll see
some of my favorite gear including the
one shirt that I've been traveling with
and until next time thank you for
listening